easy okay so what percent of women what
percent of women do you think are
virgins on their wedding day okay so if
someone wants to be yeah wait wait
another mom cannot be a virgin okay
we're gonna we're gonna go we're gonna
go into this later but but I want to say
what percent of women are virgins on
their wedding
in the west all right can we can we
answer the question probably about 25 25
okay who who thinks it's higher
okay all right
it's five percent what percent of women
have been on birth control at some point
in their life
which is all good and well until we
start looking at the body count
statistics where the where after a woman
has had five Partners her chance of a
happy marriage drops to twenty percent
okay so and the average woman has slept
with more than five men okay which
remember historically a hundred years
ago 85 percent of women were virgins on
their wedding nights now what else does
the men men get out of marriage they get
loyalty but not today because half of
women leave
then then we start to go into weight
where women are overweight the average
woman is five 370 these are just numbers
and yet we scream misogyny at me but
these are these are just numbers now I'm
and it's like I can't say numbers
without being called sexist when they
are true
I'm a family therapist and they make big
research and I have a lot of numbers 80
percent of women decide to divorce
that woman choose but women choose from
Men Who choose here
women choose but first for example if
you have one room and you have fun five
men from these five men you choose men
who choose you one might make you sick
now I like you I smile you you go and
you choose from man who choose you if
men don't like you if not has sex
attraction you cannot do anything first
men need to go up and say I want this
woman and then you choose from Men Who
choose you first second you're totally
right we are women I make my book about
entrepreneur and it's absolutely in
numbers we are women we are not so smart
like men we cannot make many things
which make men never ever because our
brain is different it's different we
cannot we cannot run so fast we cannot
make some big numbers you are totally
right that the business which make we
are women it's psychologist coach and
Beauty it cannot be my old man and if a
woman for good she's a woman she become
to be sick every day work with women who
cannot be pregnancy today is the biggest
problem in our society in UK and what
they are do they become to be men she
have a lot of cortiso she has opinion
about oh this is it messes up to be a
feminist and after she came to me like
family the representative I want to be
pregnant what you do 40 years you hate
men you hate your father you try to show
that you have big balls and after
yourself I want to be a woman what you
did before you need first to be a woman
and woman it's a totally different
Quality quality which you need to
survive as a man you need to be strong
and we know usually what woman today
tell to me Natalia I want to find the
man which very kind very rich very good
looking a very sexy love me like a crazy
he's a very crazy to accept my child he
want to take care about him about my
child he wants to marry me and from some
reason he's single in 40 years old
and of course she couldn't find it after
she is very disappointed and you are
right that woman choose but probably
that women have too high expectation she
want to be a princess she doesn't want
to change herself to go to fitness to
take care about how she looks how she
speak with men how she listen man
because the woman must listen not to
speak you need to speak 10 and 90 you
need to listen and to speak exactly
admiring admire your man admire to him
admire him and about Sin down separation
has big difference you can be separate
with your partner but he continued to
help you he continued to help your child
he continued to take care about you he
continued to be your best friend and to
call you every time when you need him if
you make normal relationship you must do
divorce only when you have Financial
dependence loyal Independence your
emotional stability you love yourself
you are a love your partner but you can
develop because you say I want something
else and you continue to say your child
your father is the best man in the world
and your child if he can be divorced but
he can love both of parents and not have
psychological trauma you can be in
marriage to be in toxic relationship and
you can destroy your child a woman must
to love it's the most important mission
of women which forgot not compare with
man you are not a man you are a woman I
agree with that can I follow on from
what you're saying I I agree with a lot
of what you're saying in the terms of
when women and men were physiologically
different mentally we're different our
brains are wired differently I think men
crave and demand respect even in
marriage if I don't respect my husband I
can't expect my husband to love me in
the way that I want to be loved if I
don't give him the respect there's a
book I read I can't remember the artist
the artist the author's name it's
literally called respect and love and if
you don't give each to the other one the
other needs and what the other ones it
becomes a crazy cycle so if I don't give
my husband the respect he's not going to
love me the way that I want and he will
give me love but ultimately he wants me
to respect him and not a respect that I
should be submissive and oh yes sir you
know kneeling on the floor every time he
says jump in and say oh how high no he
needs to give me a level of respect too
can I say it will only work if you love
and respect yourself 100 can I just
carry on from what you mentioned when I
um when I started to live with my
husband he said to me that you need to
you need to remember that you have a man
because I'll do things like carry all
the bags independent independently buy
myself to the door and he'd say why
didn't you call me so it's just learning
little things that I had to do to be
more feminine and understand that I am
in the marriage and there are roles I
know people don't like to
um the terminology of gender roles but
sometimes they are in in a marriage or
in a relationship where men need to feel
like they are men they need to feel like
their woman needs them to some extent
and that's what I had to learn I had to
learn I had to relearn how to be
feminine because I was single for so
long I kind of forgotten it by yourself
yeah I've kind of forgot how to depend
on a man I had that with my father Oh
Daddy please Daddy please oh yes yes and
he'd give me whatever I wanted but
that's also the sense of him being
needed my father knew that I needed him
and he provided so it was the same in my
marriage I need you and he provided but
when I don't let him know that he's
needed like me getting up on a chair and
trying to change a light bulb myself I
know how to do it uh-huh baby can you
come and please you know I don't really
want can you yeah of course he'll come
and do it so it's those little things
that also add to um to making your man
know that you do need him you might not
well you might not need him but you
allow him to feel needed even though you
can do it and that's kind of the
feminine femininity and masculinity in
the relationship the the yin and the
Yang that goes together collectively
Pearl I would like to just stand up for
your show
um I think they're trying to essentially
say that this show is promoting misogyny
when literally all you did was give all
of these ladies a platform to speak on
it's it's not Pearl's fault that there's
these ladies speak the way they do
for example for example the lady over
here is screaming misogyny yet she
doesn't even know the definition
you know exactly what I meant by carry
on
I don't have to take a dictionary if you
know what I don't have to say to you in
a dictionary English word by word you
know exactly but what I mean but the
reason why you know I just said to you I
basically reply to you is when you take
away where you basically don't
acknowledge don't acknowledge a woman
what women go for it a systemic it's
almost it's very that's one male side
it's a form of Oppression it's a form of
Oppression towards women misogyny has a
specific definition
what is it then tell me it's education I
could actually tell you
everybody
I need to reiterate the rules because if
you keep doing this you'll be kicked off
the show unfortunately but the reality
is
whether you like it or not language
exists for a reason women keep talking
about oh communication this
communication that women are better at
communicating than men yet
in the same breath you would say a word
and misuse it and then still argue that
what you think it means is the
definition when it clearly isn't Okay
the reason why I can confidently say
this is because like I said before this
is episode 137 we've done this show 137
times and every single time a woman has
used the word misogyny we have come to
find out that she doesn't know the
meaning so is it wrong for me to be able
to now make an analytical logical
conclusion that you probably don't know
the meaning as well what's your opinion
it's not an opinion that's your opinion
this is how science is is propagated
unless you gave you examples of it by
you know an example definition if I want
to ask you what's the definition of a
woman I'm sure you probably don't even
know that as well
hahaha
I think it's too
much
seconds
do you know the crazy thing is you've
talked more than anyone like you've
talked to the most of the show out of
all the guests are you referring to you
I'm not even saying anything no you were
just talking the whole show and you'll
say it to me pushing an agenda I can't
make words come out of your mouth and
the crazy thing thing is I'm just so
tired of this narrative that women are
oppressed in any way women are not ever
met women are more likely to get custody
of their CH of their children women are
more likely to get child support alimony
men are more likely to commit suicide
men do the hardest jobs men are the
majority of workplace deaths and yet
women will live in a society that men
built and cry misogyny and oppression
um I have a question from this lady here
um just correct me if in case I
understood drawing you said that men are
more clever than women have I heard it
correctly exactly okay how you can
um how you can prove that they have very
big difficult medical things when
approvement exists to part of brain and
show The Logical way for example if men
play chess he can play 10 steps they
make the same experiment with women can
be maximum five your brain not have
deepest level which have meant it's
approved it's approved if you're
interested it means IQ it's main IQ it's
meant how deep he can make if you take
all statistic a woman we cook every day
but chefs is always men women can be
nurse but the biggest men who make
operation it's men women can help and
manage things but owner of business
that's meant if you open the Forbes
because I'm a big research in my life
and I have academic two high education
of psychology
clinical medical psychology I work in
hospital and I have experience about
this and yes I can say with absolutely
numbers if you're not new you can check
on Google here's something clever much
stronger also try to check in the tennis
faster because they have in all his
biggest we can not we cannot this lady
in the red is you know the lady in the
red is actually nailing it I mean it's
and it's a shame that women like the one
in the red get you know suppressed
canceled uh because she's actually
saying common sense you know I work just
so you know I work with fashion models
in New York for about 10 years I was a
nightclub promoter and I Pearl and I
were talking about this where the the
Eastern European models and comparing
them to the Brazilian models and the
Eastern European ones that were way more
uh traditional submissive
and they respected the man you know they
didn't give a [__] maybe how he looked
Brazilian ones might have loved it they
had fun Playboy but the but the Eastern
European women they had a standard of
expectations of what they wanted from a
man they wanted a strong man they placed
that higher as a life partner but then
they were willing to give that in return
the problem is when women want all X Y
and Z but they're not when it suits them
but then they also want X Y and Z when
it you know they want their cake and eat
it too man it just it can't work that
way it doesn't work that way and I think
you I think you you describe I think I
think I I don't have very much
discussion over whatever you said is I'm
completely disagree when you said men
are more clever than women because I'm
in clinical field as well okay so I'm
working in the hospital as well and IQ
we have seven types I just seven types
of IQ that you know have recognize we
have a sport IQ have a math IQ have it
either you can say generalize that a
woman are less clever how many
discovered it has a woman how many
discovered how many discoveries has a
woman okay how many children have how
many philosophic has a women how many
artists has the women no open Google no
this is billionaires let's talk about
the billionaires the richest women
billionaires divorce that's the funniest
thing the most successful women got
their money why from my divorce has my
relationship with the IQ um
but I'm asking about outcomes so the
women with the most money how did they
get there was it was it through being so
smart and competent
let's let's let's think about I'm
thinking about our female billionaires
one has a sex tape one sells makeup and
the others got their money rmx model
yeah and I work in healthcare when Amex
model you're you're a model I'm a model
okay and you work in healthcare and I
work in a healthcare yes okay great and
I have a black belt in karate okay but I
bet you he could still say and if you
say that Romans are not clever
we can't say who is aware we have to say
I think we can look at the outcomes so
we could see who who is not an outcome
is which category you know the men can't
be a better Runner if the if they run
with women because they have
testosterone they have a bigger muscles
okay not because they are more clever
they active you know the sport IQ then
they hire but you can compare this lady
with this lady okay this man comparing
the man you said once one time you said
men are different with women their brain
is different their size is different and
then you compare the IQ together it's
absolutely wrong exactly absolutely I'm
looking I'm looking at
nothing looking at what well I don't not
beautiful I'm not talking about beauty
no you said Beauty I said we monetize I
I said okay let's talk about value added
to Society what makes Society run okay
no no no no wait wait wait wait wait
wait let me let me love you I need you
remember remember
Mike again all right this is your final
warning one more time you're gonna go
okay so
I'm sorry
all right thank you thank you all right
all right wait what did you say
okay actually you can go now thank you
goodbye yeah goodbye um Security will
escort you out
wow yeah that's pretty yeah I I've
warned you like three times
to stop over talking me we read you the
rules at the beginning of the show it's
all right go ahead everyone tell them no
all right and now you're gonna keep
talking back goodbye goodbye Go please
please exclude my conversation
everything
no it's live so I'll see ya
it's very important you didn't invite me
now I didn't want to yeah but calling
the people advise me I bought
okay I put okay all right
okay all right
okay I mean if you knew all that you
could have just followed the rules
though
y'all see how y'all see how bro it's
like y'all see how her emotions just
took over though right it's just a clear
example of how everything she was saying
was [__] she doesn't like it
all right so clearly that's a clear
example can you take her out please
thank you
no no she doesn't no go take out you
take yourself okay no no no no no no
that's not yourself no no no
um
no no please leave please leave
leaves
this is the problem like actually just
leave please
no take her out take her out can I just
say I don't take her get out get out
hold on don't worry about it it's just a
it's just a show it's just a show it's
just a show
it's just a show I respect you but it I
just just sit down and have a good show
I don't want you to leave no no good I
don't want good right now she's go just
please be respectful that's all she's
saying
I'm good
I'm so sorry if I base my time okay yeah
just watch out bro watch out bro she's a
black belt in karate
foreign
watch out you
are you going to publish this end of
this conversation yes goodbye goodbye
goodbye
I don't remember what we're talking
about
um
yeah I don't care go ahead
can I speak so you said you're a
psychologist
why do you think why do you think men
are more clever what's the psychology
behind that you know it's about to
understand who you are and which energy
you have more female or male of course
exist now a lot of male women where are
you where are you from oh I have a long
story I born in Russia after I live many
many years
um I have experience in mind it's 19
years and I know all about relationship
and we're sure in something men they're
very strong and we need to respect them
and some think women they're very strong
and women were most drunk and emotional
you are right that men cannot live to
live without us and we also give
inspiration of men and we have very big
role for men and women just need to
understand what is your role well my
issue is I'm not just talking about the
infrastructure Society so it's like if
we're not doing if we're not making the
most money if we're not doing the most
dangerous jobs how can we say we have an
equal impact as men when it comes to
running Society it's the biggest problem
biggest problem and the problem if men
make less money than women very often
it's disappear sexual attraction because
automatically we are women not because
we want money money from and of course
so it's great I like to receive gifts
help of men but if men all time have
less money than women he come to be her
son
and she doesn't respect him we are women
we must respect men who are stronger and
bigger than us otherwise we can very
like him you can know my son you're my
cute boy and we become to be like mother
and son and man inside us he also hid if
we are more stronger because he not feel
correct and not feel good with us and
it's uh before many years when we live
in cave might go he take one big meal
and say her wife it's your meal eat it
and she cooked and she did now a woman
say you know a meal which you gave me
it's not enough I can make it faster and
bigger yeah and the woman says stay home
and Cave they care about child I go to
make a huntering I will take a man I
will take a meal and now I'm uh begin to
switch your headphones just so you know
so you take off that ones you have put
those on just because otherwise it's
gonna yeah there you go by the way I'm
curious no by the way while you were
gone did you uh look up the definition
of misogyny no no way
me saying that if I fit in five if I
feel I don't understand what the issue
is it's my it's an opinion that I have
that I feel there's a lot of things that
go against it that's like me calling
women but that's that's like me calling
someone fat and not knowing what that is
good if you're doing things are against
women or okay
what is against women like I just want
to know what is against women what do
you mean what is again because you say I
say things that are against women what
is against women can I say something oh
I think I'm not hello I'm not going to
speak for you I can't even speak hello
I'm not going to speak for you it's when
you're online not racism but it's not
like Sexes and Prejudice towards certain
[Music]
and it's okay for me to feel that way
this is my feeling this is my opinion
from this is just off the back of what
you're saying there's some statements
that people can make and as yourself as
a host that you've made it puts the
women in a negative light oh we know
what do women's uh are they true what it
might not be true that's your opinion
you're saying facts and all of that we
can go and Google we're not we're not
allowed to be on off and that's part of
the rules right I'm sure if I could go
on Google right now and bring out
something I can break us some facts same
way this lady here Natalia she's
researched and done some studies she's
got her her area of expertise there's so
many women as well that have contributed
loads of you know perfect things not
perfect things loads of great things in
society look at when you know England
and whatever went to war and all the
soldiers went who were called to come
and help rebuild wait wait wait who is
defending the society though they
couldn't even work in the factories if
the men were defending the society okay
but that's it shows up how they were
part of the infrastructure they were
able to help rebuild
do you know what's crazy one
um women can't become Navy SEALS or
whatever the highest black Salon because
they can't physically do it and they're
lowering standards of the military
because they want to include women which
I think is a bad thing I think they keep
telling us we're equal to men and we are
not I think they keep saying that we can
do the same things that men can do and
we cannot I don't think that makes me
mean or misogynistic I think it's it's
true there are certain things that
physically women cannot do that only men
can do to a certain degree you have
categories the same way in Olympics
you're not going to put a woman to
compete against a man because
physiologically you can't compete if
there's a weightlifting Championship
women
do right okay so if you enter a man's
world then compete be a man and if you
can't do it but they don't do that
though the thing is they're going to
have categories women are going to
compete against women men are going to
compete against men when there's a race
you were talking about women can't run
as fast it's been fine we can accept
that so you raise you stay in your lane
you're saying you're
it was actually men who invented these
things because if I came up with an
invention and I said babes um progress
this for me please I'm sure he would be
happy I just want to understand I just
want to understand your premise so your
premise right now is that all the
inventors it was their wives actually
but it's so crazy because when a woman
accomplishes something we never say oh
it was probably the man behind her in
general and I might do that but but in
general in society right but vice versa
so it's like we we say all of the things
that that men have accomplished we
attribute them to women in some way
probably because historically men were
the leaders in society women are told to
be quiet as you mentioned previously we
listen more so even if we do even if we
did invent something it would be the men
to carry it Forward because they are
true one of the first one of the
earliest millionaires in in the U.S one
of like the very first millionaire was
was a woman and she I don't remember
what she invented between yeah yeah and
so and this is like another this is a I
can't I can't answer but I know she was
the first female millionaire and this is
like um this this is a narrative that
woman couldn't have Heist have couldn't
be influential in society that women
couldn't talk it's just incorrect there
are like Cleopatra Joan of Arc there
have always been high IQ women that have
been very impactful in society there
have been
um queens and rulers that men have
traveled thousands of miles to get
wisdom from this idea that women just
could not get ahead as
women can get ahead and if we're gonna
go on facts obviously I can't bring up
my facts now but we know that that women
have been silenced since in in many
situations if you look at different
cultures different contexts you know
women don't have the same voice or not
given the same voice or the opinion to
speak up as men or even if they do speak
they're not her because women your place
is to stay on the side you know be
something no but I'm saying that's not
true it's true in certain contexts two
things two things can be true at once
that's the thing we have to look at
things in you know why their perspective
in a big perspective just because it's
not true here it doesn't mean it's not
true
whatever but whenever I like refute a
point it's like you guys are like
jumping through hoops to try to make us
the victim I'm not making it
women are not victims you
because you mentioned Nigeria yeah back
in the day if you were to trace it back
into history because she's very right
women have always nothing Society has
never said and it has never been in law
where women can't do anything yes the
reality is most people throughout
history couldn't do anything it was
usually the elites and the rich people
that could do stuff and the women in
those Realms could do whatever they
wanted to do yes
of course they were why why do we know
Cleopatra why do we know why do we know
why do we need to ask him why do we know
all the female inventors CJ Walker yes
this woman that helped to release slaves
in America
um
because if you are excellent you will be
celebrated the reason why most people
are not women were oppressed is because
most people were seen as less than all
throughout history at the time yeah so
it wasn't women that were being
oppressed women were being oppressed in
a certain way and men were being
oppressed in a different oh I agree with
that I agree with you even women I know
we're not going to make it about race
but even when we look at a race that was
him so many people have been getting
oppressed because of race and it's the
same way you can race is a category so
it's a social construct you know women
yes we are physiological you can Mark Us
by the way we are that's women but men
don't necessarily look at your body and
see okay she's women they will look at
you you know you're talking about our
society society as well how Society
thinks
that's how they look at you as a woman
they would they will put you know
perspectives and mindsets on you because
you're a woman now I think you have a
privilege as a woman I think it's easier
no I think as a young woman you have so
much privilege in society more than men
yeah in general yes absolutely
I I agree with that because I have six
brothers and when I first come to
England there are certain comments my
brothers made and they were more like
but it's easier for you being a woman
and I do agree with that there are
certain things special culture it's much
harder for them you know as a man to go
out and start like for us we can get
and like you said we get attracted by so
many men they want to take care of us
it's much easier for us I totally well
and there's so many women's shelters
that help us yeah there are no men's
shelter yeah it's true
what are you talking about women's
shelters what the abuse yes there's what
about what about male victims of abuse
yeah
because it's a highly disproportionate
no it's actually so so the majority the
majority no no because why the majority
the majority the majority the majority
of abuse is mutual meaning they are both
hitting each other yes and so and so and
you know what's crazy was when they
looked into it they found that one-sided
abuse it was more likely the woman to
hit the man and the man hit the woman
and the other part we don't talk about
is all the false abuse allegations
especially in this country because there
are incentives for women to falsely
accuse men of abuse because what they do
is they expand the definition of abuse
and to goddamn anything they have
Financial abuse emotional abuse they've
expanded it and what what they do is
there is incent Financial incentives for
women to falsely accuse men
because they get free lawyers in child
support or in um Family Court I'm not
taking that away for you from you but
the percentage is extremely small so no
it's actually exactly so it's actually
it's a roughly I can't remember exactly
but it's around for roughly 10 to 20
percent of women that file abuse and
family court actually go to criminal
court and in family court it's based on
a balance of probabilities that's
actually not based off of evidence but
it's not it's not based on I'm guilty
it's basically guilty until proven
innocent or vice versa and I have a lot
of experience interviewing these guys
and family
organizations out there that do support
male men can be victims of domesticated
however however it's because of society
how we've used how we view men men are
meant to be strong you're meant to be a
leader oh my God no way can a man come
forward and say my wife abuses me yes
you're right there's so many categories
when it comes to domestic abuse not just
physical it can be Financial it can be
mental it can be so many other you know
aspects so a man will feel shame a
mouthful shame you know God forbid he's
to come out and say oh my God I mean
there are organizations that do support
them I don't know about shelters
real quick yes to your point are women
better at some things than men yes for
example if you and I were to box I would
probably win but I can almost guarantee
you that you can suck [__] better than I
can
what do you not have a mouth it's the
same mouth that you're going to use if
you're going to suck [__] isn't it so
who's it what that's the same house
I have a conversation and be mature I
have a bottom lip and I have a top lip
and I have a tongue so do you so if you
want to suck [__] you go ahead and do
that I'm not gonna compete with you now
if you don't want to have a mature
conversation I'm being mature
I don't know how we went from domestic
abuses
that's just the silly
I'm not sure
I'm not one to intervene but I came here
invited to this podcast
literally I I got here it took me two
hours to drive here I looked at no
disrespect to anybody but I've never
been to this part of London I'm
petrified even getting out of my car
here I don't belong in this side of the
world I belong in the countryside I I
gotta now get out in the dark get to my
car with this dude security guy who I
love thank you you're gonna take me to
my car but I did not come here to have
conversations about cook I don't even
use them if you give somebody to talk to
your wife like that we told you would
you like that if I never would actually
agreeing with you no no that's not how
you agree
sorry I'm so sorry
you need to understand Italian
Italian
[Applause]
[__] wait wait wait King go ahead
um guys please can we just remember the
rules yeah I get it we're all having fun
but let's just try and because we have
people at home watching yeah okay it's
disrespectful to me but hold on I've
raised my hand so I do want to make a
point next yeah I mean what did you say
before I just want to ask you she said
men think about [__] all the time so I
just want to carry on with my point I'm
making no problem and going off on a
point you said I mean this is not why I
came here on this podcast to talk about
[__] and whatever and to me I do find
that disrespectful yes cook is aware of
everyone who use that however the point
that I was made I don't remember the
point I was making before because your
point I found it disrespectfulness it's
not very ladies
things come on I can't control the
entire conversation we can't we can't
but we're talking about respectful that
was part of the rules but we need to
respect each other and I felt
disrespected if somebody came and spoke
too off about that being a married man
is that would you be happy about that I
thought we're having I'm sorry I thought
I was invited here to talk about adult
issues I think all the ladies are being
highly offensive disrespectful to Pearl
who's given all of you ladies this great
platform I was invited here
I had a difference of opinion that's all
I think personally do you feel like we
are disrespecting yeah you guys have
been quite quite rude a lot of you yeah
you do say is very offensive right but
you can you can be offended you know you
can be offended and still not over talk
people and and cry and scream into the
mic like I'm sorry sometimes you know
I've been offended plenty of times on
shows and I don't you know over talk
people cry and scream into the mic
especially on a show that's not mine by
the way the definition of misogyny is
the dislike contempt you know and
disdain of women so Prejudice so you
basically said exactly what no no no no
words
see she's doing it again and there it is
okay okay
this is the crazy thing and they say I'm
pushing an agenda and yet this is this
is how you act it's a shame it's like
it's a shame Pearl's not getting a Nobel
Peace Prize
honestly that you deal with this five
nights
I have another interesting question
what's the meaning of prejudice
ask yourself that no because no don't
come here
it is it is you know what come on come
on you're being very condescended you're
being thankful everything you've said
I'm actually not being understand I'm
trying to be very polite everything you
please move on
I told you I gave you examples
so many different examples
you could have Googled in the bathroom
you'd so much it doesn't matter this
one's saying with people when it's all
about peace you don't change I feel like
you guys you guys don't try and have a
conversation you guys try to do realize
throw out people you draw out people and
that's the reason all right all right
all right so it's a discussion do you
know what's interesting
exactly she yells over everybody
literally okay okay okay she yells over
everybody and cries about this okay that
doesn't go now
I didn't I actually I'm gonna be honest
I don't invite anybody my recruiters
what's the definition of prejudice
oh wow the baby the baby mother divorcee
is relaxing what's the definition
bad she's overweight it's like the fat
baby
muck to me about being married get out
of here get out of you started you
started man yeah yeah goodbye I'll see
ya okay then please leave
what up wow wow wow yeah wow
yeah
yeah I'm very I'm very unhappy wow wow
this is so funny man man
please can I say something if you want
women to look good ma'am ma'am ma'am if
you want women to look good please
please just stop talking
I'm fine go